elle dégage et je partirai maîtrise de
soi gestion du stress et surtout
communication autant de notions
essentielles pour sécuriser les
interventions des policiers municipaux
pendant trois jours au parc des sports
du bout des clots de maurepas ils ont
été formés au self défense et à son
cadre légal
l'intérêt pour les policiers municipaux
de mort pas de suivre cette formation
c'est de leur garantir
d'intervenir pour en toute sécurité mais
également en cours au dessus tout en
respectant les droits fondamentaux de la
personne bien sûr ils les agents de
surveillance de la voie publique non
autorisée à porter des armes étaient eux
aussi intégré à la formation pour être
formés aux techniques de maîtrise
d'individus depuis deux ans la ville de
maurepas a choisi de renforcer sa police
municipale en quadruplant son effectif
passant de deux à huit agents suite à la
signature d'une convention coordination
nous avons demandé l'autorisation en
préfecture de doter notre police
municipale d'armes de catégorie d donc à
savoir des bâtons de défense et des
bombes lacrymogènes pour la catégorie d
il n'y a pas de formation obligatoire
mais nous avons souhaité que les agents
soient formés au maniement de ce
matériel à l'issue de cet apprentissage
le formateur fera passer aux agents un
test d'aptitude une demande de porc
individuelles seraient ensuite rédigé au
préfet sous réserve d'un avis médical
favorable